Let's go next to our caller from the 7 1 6
area code who's calling today from 7 1 6.
Hey, David.
Hey, who's this?
This is a from Buffalo, hey, Xavier, what's
up?
All right, so.
I can't support Joe Biden.
I'm sorry, but his record of segregation,
crime, the crime bill and his allegations
were terror Reid.
I can't support him, but I will say this.
I do.
Would you agree that it is the most important
thing that we do is to flip the Senate?
Because if you think about it, if Donald Trump
gets reelected and you have a Republican Senate,
that's gonna be a disaster, you're going to
get more terrible policies passed if you have
a Joe Biden presidency, but you have a Republican
Senate.
I fear that that's going to enable Biden into
our work to work with Republicans more, to
do less, to do like horrible things, maybe
like Social Security, Medicaid, because he
says he is willing to put that on the table.
Right.
But I do think if you so much more on a second.
Let me let me let's back up.
So.
Okay.
Hold on.
So in the 90s, Joe Biden said he would not
rule it.
So I don't even care about that.
This is old stuff.
But I think it's important for people to understand
when you say Joe Biden is considering cutting
Social Security and Medicare.
Joe Biden during it was either an interview
or a debate in the 90s, said he wouldn't a
priority take off the table cuts to Social
Security and Medicare.
Joe Biden didn't propose any such cuts.
And that was almost 30 years ago.
And he's not talking about that now.
So, like, we can we can think whatever we
think about Joe Biden.
But you understand that I can't I can't let
you come in and say Joe Biden is thinking
about cutting Social Security and Medicare
when what happened was in the 90s, he said
he wouldn't apriori taken off the table, but
he's not advocated for it.
And he certainly isn't running on that now.
You know that, right?
We are now running on debt now by Seema Yasmin
Pacis.
In the 90s, when he was asked in a situation,
he said I wouldn't blindly take it off the
table.
Now, I disagree with that position.
I would say we're not cutting it.
He didn't say it in the 90s, but that has
nothing to do with what he's running on now.
I don't want people to hear that and think
the wrong thing.
So here's my my perspective.
I don't think there's any sense in me saying
it's more important that Biden beat Trump
or it's more important that Democrats take
the Senate.
These are separate elections and they will
very much go together.
So, for example, in a state like Montana,
Biden is.
He's losing, but he's polling way better than
Democrats have done in the past.
And the incumbent Republican senator in Montana
is losing right now to Steve Bullock.
So there's not really this one or the other
thing.
And there are going to be decided separately,
although they seem to move in parallel.
If Biden does really well, it's more likely
that a bunch of Republican senators would
lose.
So I don't think it's the right approach to
say it's more important to take the Senate.
It's it's actually these things are linked.
And you can vote you get a vote for the Senate
and you get a vote for president.
And we can do both.
OK.
All right, Xavier, thank you very much, appreciate
the phone call.